if we if we lose the greenland ice sheet
and we flood the coastal cities the way
to reverse that is to just take a hose
and drain the oceans and put it back
into greenland but you have to be cold
enough for it to still freeze so that's
all you have to do i just i just solved
that problem there you go i don't know
why you do great all right let's do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
so i got with me of course chuck nice
hey hey
all right all right and this topic
climate change you're you you've been
into that even before you were start
talking
yes i have to admit that uh it's it's
one of my passions i don't have a lot of
passions but it's one no that's good
it's really good and you can take your
skill set and bring it to conferences
and have people uh you know because
people i've found that they they're more
committed and motivated if they can at
least sort of smile uh and say yeah that
that's good i like that let me do more
of that and let me feel this way some
more by doing something good for the
world you know hit it on the head man
that's the idea the idea is if we can
get people to think about what is an
existential crisis uh without thinking
of it and doom and gloom but
in a way that they might take action
that's the whole whole idea yeah there
you go there you go and so we think of
you as a climate activist
in your free time i like that
will you take that
wait translation the worst activist ever
oh
late the lazy activist okay yeah that
guy's he's a man that guy's an awesome
activist whenever he has time
you know he's very committed when he has
an afternoon free
okay i didn't mean it that way no i look
like it i love it
okay now i follow climate science but
i'm not i'm the expert and you're an
activist so we need someone who's who
knows what they're talking about yeah
and we of course found right up the
street here in new york city climate
scientist kate marvel kate welcome back
to star talk
hello i'm so excited to be here yes
excellent you're a research scientist at
nasa's gis
that's the goddard institute for space
studies uh and your research scientist
at columbia university
which has a lot of overlapping uh
scientists and uh and research interests
with nasa at your division there and my
my favorite part of your your resume
here that you have a phd in theoretical
particle physics
from cambridge and you say all right now
i'm done with that let me just fix the
world right so
so i'm loving it i'm loving it and so
how cool is it to be bored with
theoretical particle physics
so so kate can you explain to take a
minute to explain what you do
daily sure um so i work with climate
models which are basically toy planets
that you put on a computer um and
they help us
see they help us do experiments um
experiments that we can't do on the real
planet um so they let us
on the real planet right
the way you said that is that you know
if we could we would no no no
you don't want to do some of those on
the real planet i presume well
i mean we are
all doing a collective very big very
serious experiment on this planet right
now
without knowing the consequence right
totally right it doesn't seem very smart
but yeah climate models are great
because they let you do they project the
future they let you say okay if
emissions continue to rise this is what
the world will look like if we cut
emissions this is what the world will
look like but they also help you do
counterfactual experiments like
what if there were no rocky mountains um
what if a giant volcano went off
tomorrow
um what if we weren't putting any carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere um so i it's
kind of like playing with sims all day
but with math and physics because you
have this toy planet and you can do
experiments on it and that teaches you
something about how the real world works
so i didn't know there's another word
for what if
counterfactual
okay
that sounds fancy already right right
okay i'm sticking with what ifs
if
chuck you collected questions this is
not the first time we've done a climate
uh cosmic queries so it's a very popular
topic with our audience and chuck has
collected questions from our patreon
members so
uh they get exclusive access
to our guests in this format so chuck
give me a few here okay here we go let's
do this uh this is
hitting
wegmans who says or uh hi dr tyson and
dr marvel lord nice
if we
could do as thanos suggested
killing half of the humans
would that stop or slow down climate
change and yes i was inspired by dr
marvel's last name to ask this question
marvel universe yes
so also for you neil greetings neil from
the netherlands oh neither lands i love
that okay
yeah so so so kate this this person is
asking the ultimate counterfactual
question if
if the marvel universe is real and
there's such a evil
as as thanos and he snapped his fingers
and got rid of half the life
what
is that a model you guys have done
on your computers
so um yeah i want to be totally clear
let's not do that um terrible idea um
but the problem like i think that gets
to a really important point um the
problem with climate change it's not
people it's the actions of people so
climate change is happening because
carbon dioxide levels in the atmosphere
are increasing and they're increasing
because humans are doing stuff we're
burning fossil fuels we're cutting down
forests um we're raising animals that
put methane in the
atmosphere that still kind of sounds
like plantails
people don't cause climate change the
things people do cause climate change
exactly and the thing about people is we
can do different things um so we don't
have to generate electricity by burning
fossil fuels because there is a giant
nuclear fusion reactor in the sky that
we can use that moves air around our
planet
we can use wind we can use solar we can
use geothermal we can use nuclear there
are a whole bunch of different ways to
generate energy electricity for
transportation that choices release
carbon dioxide we have choices which
have choices
my great rebuttal to that question is if
thanos had that much power
why doesn't he just snap his fingers and
produce twice as much food right or fix
the process fix everything right dude
what's up with your solutions here your
big sociopath
that's your problem thanos
yeah your big sociopath
power tripping all right never mind
because they were worried about food
shortages and things just double the
amount of food with the snap of your
finger or by the way if you don't if you
even if that's not the how about make
everybody half the size they are okay
there's a movie about that there's a
movie about that
like downsizing with matt damon but like
real real marquee actors in it so i
didn't see it so i don't know if like
climate change is an issue
in the storyline
but
uh tiny people that solve a lot of
problems there are no small parts just
small actors
sorry i had to do it
all right what else you got this is deb
beach
deb beach says
greetings this is deborah from finland
ohio
are you serious i'm dead serious
yeah we won't hold that against you that
beach um
with a question of course about climate
change i have a family who challenges me
when i talk about climate change they
can't seem to understand the difference
between weather
and climate any confrontational and
positive ways to illustrate the
difference because i'm out of ideas
thanks in advance dr marvel
so this sounds like a retelling of a
thanksgiving dinner so yeah
what should what do people should we all
do with thanksgiving tell us and also
what do we do about uncle joe's drinking
problem because seriously
it's not kate's expertise okay okay
um i think thanksgiving dinners go
better when everybody just eats um but
you know if this does come up um you
know there are several ways to handle it
um one of my favorite quotes is by dr
marshall shepherd who's a climate
scientist at the university of georgia
and he says weather is your mood climate
is your personality um so weather is
changeable i have no idea what the
weather is going to be like on june 1st
10 years from now um but because i
understand the climate um of new york i
know that it's likely to be hot it's
likely to be warmer than it was in
january for example so when we talk
about climate we talk about long-term
averages whereas weather is something
that fluctuates on a day-to-day basis um
and it's really important to keep those
things separate um but at the same time
climate affects the weather because
everything happens against the backdrop
of climate
wow
so what you're saying is
uh
when people if it snows one day right
like late in the spring people say see
you climate change people are wrong
because we had a snowfall in late april
right or early april and so
that's that's like the perfect moment to
say no you're just in a mood
all right
all right chuck give me another one
all right uh this is from
uh billy bryant who says hello doctors
tyson and marvel knowing that we can
never turn back the dial on what we've
already lost how will we know when the
effects of green initiatives have
actually begun to have a positive impact
on i like that question
right i love this question okay i love
that that would help the movement right
if you can see the effects
so what do you got for us there
this is a real um bad news really good
news situation i think um so the bad
news is under any kind of reasonable
trajectory um you know we don't shut
down all fossil fuel infrastructure
immediately overnight but you know we
really get serious about this we start
cutting emissions we start building out
wind and solar um
the climate benefits of that aren't
going to start showing up for decades so
so that's kind of the bad news um the
good news is that there are a lot of
immediate what we call co-benefits
because a lot of the things that emit
greenhouse gases carbon dioxide methane
those are the same things that are
emitting what we think of as pollution
so particulate matter smog all that
really bad stuff and though getting rid
of those things cuts pollution it makes
our air quality better and there's a lot
of research that shows that that makes
our health better
that reduces inequalities that
can even increase things like labor
productivity so we start doing that we
see those benefits immediately and we
just learned about real estate
inequalities right where certain uh
disadvantaged groups are uh the only
real estate available to them is near
toxic waste dumps and this sort of thing
so right there's an entire real estate
dimension to this climate and justice
absolutely right right yeah there's a
huge justice component to it
so you're saying you're making a better
world
beyond
just saving the climate
absolutely that's kind of uh an added
bonus i think that that's a very
positive way to think about that i like
that i like that but chuck we got to
take a quick break kate oh uh when we
come i don't we'll get there we'll get
there
we're this is a cosmic queries star talk
where it's climate and we've got one of
the best around to tell us about it uh
kate marvel and so stay with us we'll be
right back
we're back star talk cosmic queries
a climate yet another climate edition of
cosmic queries one we should have weekly
weekly yeah yes yes and we've got one of
our favorite climate experts right up
the block kate marvel is up at the
goddard institute for space studies uh a
branch of nasa yeah where client
planetary climate
is their thing isn't that right kate
this is what you all you all do it right
maybe
yeah with a particular focus on the best
planet i think the bestest plant yeah
there is okay
yeah and if anybody got a problem with
that you can leave
no but also you can learn things from
other planets because there's different
phases that could inform earth but earth
has got the
earth is the
the object of people's interest of
course the ultimate object of interest
all right chuck what else do you have
for us all right let's jump right back
into this with uh
our guy matthew sweden matthew says
hello dr tyson dr marvel lord nice
there's so much talk of this point of no
return
for the effects that we
have had on our planet's climbing
what changes that we have caused if any
are actually
reversible
um yeah forget just all right we're
gonna stop impending doom
can we go back to like i don't know 1901
levels i i let me lead off with one
point and then have and pass the baton
to kate i speak with biologists almost
daily because they're my colleagues at
the american museum of natural history
there's a wave of extinction that we are
causing from all of our conduct and all
of our behavior and with the climate
change the balance of insects and other
creatures that depended on very specific
ecological niches of where they were as
the as that climate changes uh it
becomes hostile to them and can render
them extinct so one of the things that's
irreversible is extinction okay so let
me just lead off now kate they'll just
hand it to the baton take it from here
thanks a lot debbie downer and i'll give
it to kate
yeah blow us out some more kate yeah all
right what do you have for us
i mean i guess i'll start out with the
good news which is that climate change
is not pass fail it's not a binary thing
you hear a lot of times people say if we
exceed a particular temperature
threshold if we exceed 1.5 degrees
celsius or 2 degrees celsius everything
is fine up until then and then boom
everything is destroyed or we're doomed
it's a catastrophe um and both of those
things are wrong so first everything is
not fine everything is not fine right
now um the world has warmed about 1.2
degrees since pre-industrial times um
and it is not fine um but at the same
time nature does not think in terms of
degrees celsius
even degrees fahrenheit
there's no firm threshold where we
exceed that and all of a sudden
everything is terrible um what we have
is a lot
of changes some of which are reversible
and some of which are irreversible
things like
these extinctions those are irreversible
and the fear is that as we approach as
more and more and more warming as we put
more and more greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere and it gets warmer and warmer
we start to trigger more and more
changes that are irreversible so for
example if you melt
the west antarctic ice sheet or you melt
greenland that's a lot of ice that was
sitting on land that now is going into
the water and raising the sea levels
that is not reversible at least on time
scales that are relevant to humans um if
you make it really really warm you could
crack up the amazon and once you get rid
of the amazon it's not easy to regrow a
rain forest from scratch so there are a
lot of these changes what we call
tipping points that are irreversible um
in a human lifetime and for me the
scariest thing about these tipping
points is we can't tell you exactly when
we're going to hit them
so i can't tell you this particular
warming is safe
because no particular level of warming
is safe we do know that the risk of
these things increases the warmer it
gets and so that's why i think you know
really broken records every scientist
says every tenth of a degree of warming
matters every ton of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere matters it all matters
what you're saying is if we if we lose
the greenland ice sheet and we flood the
coastal cities the way to reverse that
is to just take a hose and drain the
oceans and put it back into greenland
but you have to be cold enough for it to
still freeze so that's all you have to
do i just i just solved that problem
there you go i don't know why you do
great all right let's do it
[Laughter]
and is
it is it everyone does something on
hoses and bricks garden hose too that's
your garden hose totally garden hose yes
yeah your ordinary garden hose that's
all you need
all right chuck what else you got
okay here we go uh
uh
i have to read this even though uh this
gentleman from patreon has been with us
before
but it's our
alejandro reynoso okay this is a this is
our thing we gotta do it now i remember
him he's from montpellier he is from
monterey
and he says
hello
i gotta do it all right what does he
have he's he's a he's an old-timer with
us i love him he is so what does he have
he's got a he's got a pretty cool
question here he says now where i live
we're going through
a tremendous drought
how often is this going to happen in the
world
and where are we going to see it the
most
so kate clearly droughts are not
something new
but do you have enough knowledge in your
models to predict whether they'll become
more frequent and if they're more
frequent does that mean you have more
rainfall somewhere else is there some
net flow of water that just gets
redistributed
yeah so we know a lot about how rainfall
patterns will change in a warming world
um we know that
on average the global ridge rainfall
will increase but that's not really any
comfort to you if you live in a like
australia or the southwest or the
mediterranean that is projected to
experience very severe drought because
rainfall will increase in some places
particular really heavy rainfall is
projected to increase and in places like
new york in fact we're seeing that um
whereas in some other areas rainfall is
projected to decrease but the thing
about drought is that even if rainfall
does
decrease even if it remains the same we
are still going to see increased drought
in many regions and that's because warm
air is thirsty air
evaporation away from the surface so
even if you're getting the exact same
amount fall if that's all getting
slurped out of your soil moisture very
very by the warmer atmosphere
be a problem right um so then it doesn't
go to your water table for example then
it goes it doesn't go to your water
table it doesn't go to plants um oh my
gosh we have evidence that what's going
on in southwestern north america is
actually the worst drought on record
ever um so going back for thousands of
years and i i just wanted to add that in
addition to
drought areas that are warm where water
should freeze the water will not freeze
and that way the snow packs don't melt
to sustain water levels so that also
leads to
more drought absolutely
give me some more what do you want okay
here we go here we go here we go
this is
peter jacobs
and peter says
it is often said
don't waste time on other planets while
we haven't fixed our own isn't it better
that we test our theories elsewhere if
possible artificial habitats allow for
much more
experimentation
there's a lot of stuff packed in there
uh yeah so kate we've heard about these
biodomes you know that was simulating
mars or or the moon or whatever so how
realistic is that relative to your what
if models
um so you know i want to say i'm a huge
supporter of doing research on other
planets the more we know about other
planets the more we know about our own
um so i think basic science is really
really important astronomy really really
important because that teaches us about
where we live that said i don't want to
live on any of the other planets um you
know i
i would hate to live on mars mars wants
to kill you
venus wants to kill you even more i
think
and so the more we learn about other
planets the more we realize how special
this particular planet is
i don't know because it's not my
particular area of expertise what
exactly technically we would need to
pack to go live on another planet and
how you fit that all and you know the
trunk of the there's trump
of course they all have chances yeah
yeah so i mean i don't know how you pack
that
um but you know i think
taking care of but just to be clear
there is a book called packing for mars
okay
uh okay and it is there's instructions
and it's packing for mars but in terms
of living on mars that's a separate
other book
you can pack to survive the trip there
after that it's
all bets are off yeah just make sure you
know make sure you pack the book about
living on mars
it's mary roach who has a whole series
of very fun books exploring the limits
of science and what they can do for us
yeah
so okay so so i'm i'm with you on this
one kate the earth is i think will
always be my priority
i love the universe but
you know i like being alive better
i think also resident in his question is
um
are your mathematical models
reliable enough that they can be
um
a i will say perfect substitute for
some type of
empirical uh experimentation a great
great way to rephrase that chuck what so
what do you have kate
um so models are always tested against
data um so we test our models of earth
against observations of earth's climate
from satellites from the ground we also
test them against reconstructions of
past climates so we say what does the
ice age look like in this particular
model and does that agree with our
reconstructions from from various
proxies um you know you also it's the
same physics that determines the climate
on earth and the climate on other
planets so you can take your climate
model and you can say all right well
given what we know about
venus
what does it tell us about the the how
do you pronounce it venusian
yeah yeah it's actually initiating
it's technically venereal
um yeah but the medical doctors got to
that word before the astronomers did so
yeah it's so remember the the russian
landers venera uh that was the name of
their series of rush of landers on venus
so
uh yeah
venereal is the
is the genitive form of venus
venereal ship i'm sorry so we just
invented a whole new word
and it's fine we will take it there
there it is
uh so time for like a couple more
like one more one more question
in this segment give me one more here
from from our patreon list all right all
right all right uh jennifer long
says hello dr marvel
what would be the top five climate
solutions
i don't care how ambitious they are
how do you feel they should be
prioritized above all others thank you
sincerely jen from dallas texas so kate
it's possible to put pie in the sky
goals but maybe they're so out of reach
people get frustrated and then they give
up so maybe there's some middle ground
between this is a big audacious goal but
i think it's it's accessible to me so
therefore i will do it so i think that's
a great question um i also think that
physicists are probably the wrong people
to ask that question too because from
our perspective
uh climate change is happening because
greenhouse gas concentrations are
increasing so how do you stop climate
change you stop doing that um
and whether it's climate models i was
thinking recently a diet book written by
a physicist it would have two words in
it it would be eat less
right
so this is why nobody asks us
[Laughter]
it hurts when i do this don't do that
yeah physicists are not all that
compassionate with your situation so so
what do you have you got you have a top
set of goals here
um i would say you know stop burning
fossil fuels um we know that so much
number one um two number two um probably
eat less meat or grow meat and fats um
or eat plant-based meat okay um i think
that would be really really turn your
diet into one with a smaller carbon
footprint however you might accomplish
it because the day might come where we
grow meat proteins and then you're not
raising farm animals to do it it would
have a lower exactly carbon footprint
than vegetarians do if all that's done
so that's interesting okay three
um three um i mean maybe this should be
number one um is don't vote for people
who don't get it uh oh my gosh yes duh
duh oh my god
yeah who's right you thought of that
like okay
right in a democracy
we create our own government right and
so
so you need an informed electorate so
that the leadership
can
has the science literacy necessary to
solve this problem very good okay um uh
let's say electrify everything um so you
know a lot of the things that we do
right now
like
yeah to a clean grid yeah right and when
you do it even if you're not there yet
you have the you know you're not there
yet you built in the capacity right to
take your energy from any of these other
sources
without changing your setup right
yeah so an electric car is better than
an internal combustion car even if most
of that electricity is not generated
from clean sources but we hope that they
will become generated by clean sources
and you know again walking biking taking
the subway those are all better than
driving an electric car but that's not
an option for a lot of people who need
to get various places right right that's
so boy you just made me
just imagine a time
where we have a clean smart grid
and then we're manufacturing
clean technologies for transportation
all the way down the line it's one big
loop
of
you know net zero yeah production
it's not zero carbon carbon zero carbon
right yeah it'd be a beautiful thing
because your the electricity used to
make the thing is clean and then the
thing itself is clean like that's pretty
awesome all around all around uh kate
we're gonna have one more segment with
you but before we take this quick break
uh what what is your foot footprint
speaking of footprints what is your uh
what is your social media footprint
um so i am on twitter as dr kate marvel
um i'm occasionally post taking a break
right now
um and that's about it
okay all right so no you're not yet on
tick-tock i'm too old for tick-tock okay
you said that with such
authority right i'm too old for
tick-tock
when we come back star talk cosmic
queries featuring climate sustainability
and our expert guest kate marvel we'll
see in a moment
we're back cosmic queries climate
and we've got our special guest expert
kate marvel
and chuck we've had her on the show
before we couldn't stop talking about
her name
that's right it's it's so superhero oh
my gosh
your your your uh social media handle
should be stan lee did not create me
though i nonetheless
be a superhero right right what you got
here and so
so kate just uh remind us what you do in
a day
sure um so i'm a climate modeler i work
with climate models which are basically
toy planets that you put on computers
and the cool thing about climate models
is that they are literally world
building machines
they help you understand the world that
we live in they help you understand what
it would be like if things were
otherwise and they let you look at
different what-ifs
and kate we know because we learn this
in movies if you have the power to
create a world
you have the power to destroy one
with with that power comes great
responsibility
so um how do you think of marvel let's
begin marvel so kate where do you get
your data from
and then how do you invoke it in the
models themselves
so a model is just physics um it just
expresses what we know about how air and
water and ice and land all react and
and interact with each other so
at its very very basic core a climate
model is just basically newton's laws of
motion you know f equals m a
energy conservation mass conservation so
it's basic physics 101 this is like the
first basic physics 101 yeah exactly
um and you know the the reason that
climate models are so complex the reason
that we have to run them on super
computers is that there are a lot of
things acting under f equals m a so
they're all interacting with each other
you've got you know all of these
different aspects of the climate system
and that gets really really complicated
it's just a bunch of differential
equations it's just a bunch of physics
but when you write it all down those
equations get really really difficult or
impossible for a human being to solve
and so you need to solve them on a
computer
i got you and so and what does
satellites do for you
so satellites help give us the data that
let us check whether or not our models
are credible or not so we've got an
amazing earth observing system at nasa
that's looking at various aspects of the
climate system so everything from the
temperature
to the cloud cover
to the color of the oceans to see what
phytoplankton is doing in the oceans so
we're tracking an incredible amount of
data from space and that gives us ways
to test hey are things changing in the
way that our models say they should be
changing but kate when i hear you say
that part of me also thinks the opposite
not the opposite but the inverse of that
if you are you creating a model wouldn't
you use data to start the model
or is all the data you're gathering from
space to check your model yeah some i
mean so some of it starts in both places
you know we have rough estimates for you
know what the average temperature of the
planet is um so we we've got a lot of
measurements that we use as kind of
initial conditions for the model you
know what the ocean looks like where the
ocean is
you know something as basic as that but
then at the time component how things
are changing
a lot of times people think that we are
using the observations in order to kind
of drive the models and that's not
necessarily the case we're using the
observations in order to check the model
that's i was trying to clarify that
that's all yeah yeah so and it's is are
there any other organizations that are
modeling uh along with you or in
opposition to you and do you guys share
information
yeah so there's a bit of a friendly
competition with different climate
modeling groups we have i think four
climate models in the united states
um ours at nasa gis there's one at
princeton one in boulder and one
developed out of the department of
energy
then there's climate models all over the
world so there's a japanese climate
model there is a chinese kind of model
there is a british climate model there's
a french kind of model and so what's
your competition just to see who matches
the data the best as it comes rolling in
i guess
well there's a whole bunch of different
ways to be wrong um
[Laughter]
you know so we're not just measuring the
average temperature of of the planet um
we're measuring you know climate models
output an incredible amount of data you
know right now i think the current
generation of climate models is giving
us about 50 petabytes of data so this is
a huge big data a petabyte is a thousand
times bigger than a terabyte terabyte
a thousand times bigger than a gigabyte
a thousand times bigger than a megabyte
so there we go we're moving on up yeah
it's a lot it's a lot so you know
they're giving us not just temperature
but rainfall and cloud cover and soil
moisture
and ice and all of these different
variables that interlock and interact
and make up the climate system so at
some point if all of you start agreeing
with each other that's a good sign
because it means that however
differently everyone was thinking from
each other at the beginning there's some
convergence of an understanding of how
the systems work is that a fair
a fair
prediction for the future
absolutely so if all climate models
agree on something that means that the
physics is incredibly well understood so
all climate models get warmer in
response to elevated carbon dioxide and
that's because the physics of the
greenhouse effect is not something that
is at all controversial
so how can an organization which
presumably has a little more power and
influence than an individual so how can
an organization
uh maybe allocate its time its money its
effort to
mitigate some of what you're you're
you're trying to
understand there so i love that question
and the reason i love it is i think
there's so much emphasis put on the
individual what can individuals do do
you recycle do you buy different light
bulbs and
no individual is going to be able to
make even a drop in the bucket of
climate change so this is really a
systemic problem and we really need
systemic solutions but no individual is
completely isolated everybody is part of
a community everybody is part of a
church group everybody has you know most
people have employers and so it's really
interesting so the concept of an
organization here is way beyond just
what is the name of your company it's
anything you are a participant in
is bigger than you are but you all might
have a like mind in order to take action
i think so yeah i think then that can be
really powerful because a you can get
stuff done when you band together in
larger groups but also it makes you feel
less alone i talk to a lot of people who
are feeling really overwhelmed and
really terrified and really anxious
and when you think of just yourself as
an individual
of course you feel anxious because what
can one individual do with such a big
problem but once you start acting and
once you start bringing in other people
in your networks your friend group your
school whatever then you start feeling
less alone and you start being able to
be more effective you're a new york
resident you may remember not weeks ago
was it it was announced that there's
there's going to be a mandate on is it
new construction or all construction
where uh you can't use a gas stove
anymore everyone is going to convert to
the uh electromagnetic induction or or
just the electric coil so that's a city
making a decision for its own future and
that's what you mean when you say this
right yeah larger organizations can make
systemic changes in ways the individual
can't and there are several cities
making that that same move there are
okay there are several cities across the
nation right now making that same move
where the gas pipes will be capped and
when you have a building you will just
have an induction you'll be cooking with
magnetism yes
[Laughter]
electromagnetism
electromagnetism it's delicious but it
doesn't roll off the tongue like chuck
when they say
you're cooking with gas now
you're cooking with electromagnetic
induction now
[Laughter]
so another very important question i
think
um kate is
often we see industries that are
invested
in a their own carbon footprint or in
denial of it and we have scientists
giving these other messages
do you have any
any advice
on how scientists in the corporate world
can make nice in the sandbox
i mean one of the most painful
realizations for me as as a scientist is
that
data doesn't change people's minds um
you know i have this temptation to show
up and when i talk to people say but i
have an equation oh you want to see
another equation you want to see a graph
i have a graph and that doesn't work
that doesn't change people's minds
i think what changes people's minds are
are stories and stories told by
messengers that they trust um and so i
realized that there are audiences that
i'm not going to be able to talk to
they don't trust me they don't see me as
a welcome messenger and and that's okay
because what we need is to get more
people involved in talking about climate
change i think that's why it is so
important for all of us to talk about
this as much as possible because if
people don't listen to me maybe they'll
listen to you kate that's profound i
like the idea there's storytellers who
the trusted storytellers
we just have to make sure that they are
educated in ways that uh their story has
some relationship to an objective
reality once upon a time there was a
planet called earth
and then i liked that story had these
things called homo sapiens come along
and they knocked it all out
the end the end okay one last question
we gotta keep this tight
how can we communicate the urgency of
this
without having people throw up their
hands oh
with without hope oh that's that's good
stuff there
yeah that something that i struggle with
a little bit um because if you say how
bad it is if you say you know this is
this is really really serious this is an
existential threat then yes people tend
to shut down people tend to get very
anxious um
and i think the way the the framing that
really works for me
is saying can you imagine how scary
climate change would be if we didn't
know what was causing it can you imagine
if there was nothing that we can do
about this that's not true there is
something that we can do about this
you know i've never thought of it that
way kate that's brilliant it's simple
and brilliant at the same time
one of the things that i one of the
things i like to say to people is um
aren't you tired of hearing about the
greatest generation
like
every time you hear anything about any
generation it's like oh yeah well we're
the greatest generation we we saved the
world we did this we did don't
don't you want to be the greatest
generation like you have an opportunity
to be the greatest generation because
when we look back on this time it will
either be that we stepped up to the
plate
or
you know we're in a world of crap one or
the other and if we step up to the plate
they'll they'll call you the greatest
generation because you you did it so
chuck you were on a roll there with your
poetic brilliance and then you said crap
it was like
that didn't fit in the narrative there
you know why
because the term is world of something
else
so you're absolutely right all right
okay we got to close this out give me
one to give us a sentence to take us
home you've been wise this entire show
now cap that with another bit of wisdom
that'll that'll take us home
oh man no pressure um i would say um we
are we are lucky we are lucky to have
been born at this time
because we are alive at exactly the
right time to change everything for the
better
so this has been star talk thanks to my
co-host chuck nice always a pleasure
tweeting at chuck nice comic always good
to have you there and thank you again to
our special guest dr kate marvel kate uh
occasionally on twitter at dr kate
marvel i've been your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist as
always keep looking up
[Music]
you